julian wenn man das so sieht kann man
eigentlich sagen das rennen ist gelaufen
für donald trump nein das rennen ist
noch nicht gelaufen auch wenn es denkbar
ungünstig aus gebürstetem aussieht für
ihn dass es eben erklärt bevor sozusagen
das augenmerk der des tram teams sich
wieder nach osten gerichtet auf die
staaten pennsylvania north carolina und
georgia müssen sie in im westen des
landes in nevada und in der sonne oder
in beiden staaten die tür öffnen du hast
gesagt in nevada glaubt man nicht mehr
das man gewinnen kann
das stimmt in gewisser weise aber in
nevada spielt sich jetzt das ab was wir
seit gestern als die größte juristische
schlacht der amerikanischen geschichte
erleben dann nämlich genau in nevada wo
immer noch gezählt wird und wo joe biden
nur mit 0,7 prozentpunkten vorne liegt
und wo interessanterweise seit gestern
abend keine stimmen mehr abgegeben
wurden
also abgegeben wurden an die zählung wir
hatten gestern abend 75 prozent der
auszählungen nevada ungefähr und seit
stunden seit gestern abend 23 uhr
deutscher zeit hat sich daran nichts
mehr getan und genau da sagen die
republikaner jetzt wenn sie daran
gehindert wurden zu wählen zum beispiel
durch lange schlangen oder weil ihre
maschine kaputt war dann melden sie das
also dieser große juristische kampf
findet jetzt in nevada statt und es ist
ganz interessant wenn man sich das mal
anguckt bisher wie gesagt 0,7 prozent
auseinander
9,06 prozent 49,34 joe biden zu 48,7
wird schon wenn man das mal auf 100 oder
beziehungsweise abrundet weil joe biden
49 49 warum glaubt dass trump lager ja
das ist da jetzt schwierig werden könnte
ich weiß nicht ob man das jetzt sehen
kann wenn man sich jetzt anschaut ich
halte das versucht es einmal in die
kamera zu halten wenn man sich jetzt
anschaut
in welchen counties dass die meisten
stimmen jetzt noch ausgezählt werden
hier sehen wir erwarten den bundesstaat
nevada zu großen teilen rot zu großen
teilen rot aber dort wo die stimmen
ausgezählt werden hier unten in clark
county clara county befindet sich las
vegas die großstadt las vegas und hier
oben in hier oben in nash county
befindet sich die großstadt renault die
beiden großen städte im bundesstaat
nevada und diese städte
mit ihrem glücksspiel mit ihrem leichten
lockeren leben wenn man das mal so
zurückhaltend ausdrücken möchte
die neigen durchaus dazu demokratisch zu
wählen also in diesen beiden counties in
denen immer noch die großen stimmen
gezählt werden die großen anteile der
stimmen dort liegt in los legte joe
biden mit 50,8 prozent vorne und donald
trump und in clark county liegt beiden
mit 52,9 prozent vor
das heißt in den counties in den steht
zwar unentschieden aber in den counties
in denen gezählt wird
dort liegt der beiden bisher vorne das
heisst donald trump muss in diesen
beiden counties das stimmverhältnis was
es bisher gibt das muss ja irgendwie
versuchen umzudrehen und braucht in
beiden ja ich würde mal sagen so 54 bis
55 prozent der verbleibenden stimmen
obwohl er bisher 50 rund 50 prozent
geholt hat das heißt er muss sich um
fünf prozentpunkte dort steigern und das
ist etwas was so spät im prozess
besonders unwahrscheinlich ist wenn es
um großstädte geht in denen die minority
wort sitzt also die die die wahlstimmen
von minderheiten die tendenziell auch
nicht besonders stark aber tendenziell
im moment zu die beiden lagen und damit
wir vielleicht noch mal über arizona
sprechen richtig sprechen wir über
arizona arizona ist ein bundesstaat den
tramp 2016 gewonnen hat und der dann in
der vergangenen nacht beziehungsweise
eine nacht von dienstag auf mittwoch
plötzlich überraschend an die demokraten
gegen fox news hat das ausgerufen wurde
danach heftigst kritisiert von der tramp
kampagne
warum glaubt dass trump team daran dort
und zwar ohne juristische wege sondern
auf ganz natürlichem wege der auszählung
doch noch gewinnen zu können
also in arizona ist die lage höchst
komplex in arizona haben sowohl fox news
wenn man so will der herzen sender von
donald trump und die nachrichtenagentur
associated press den start für joe biden
gecallt cnn die zu einem konsortium
mehrerer großer nachrichten marken
gehören das an dem sich eigentlich das
wahlgeschehen in den usa orientiert
haben diesen staat noch nicht gekauft
das heißt die stimmen aus arizona sind
noch nicht zu der beiden geflossen und
denn auch da läuft noch die auszählung
und auch da können wir das vielleicht
einmal kurz zeigen
wir haben hier den bundesstaat arizona
50,52 48,1 steht es dort für joe biden
aber wieder dort wo gerade ausgezählt
wird wo die den großteil der noch nicht
gezählten stimmen noch ruht dort
befinden sich zwei großstädten wir sehen
dass hier die sauna ist relativ
fragmentiert viel rot hier und da aber
andererseits auch viel blau hier unten
diese beiden flecken mit der stadt 50
maricopa county und pina account die mit
den städten phoenix und tucson die
beiden großen städte in arizona das sind
die orte an denen noch ausgezählt wird
und diese orte lehnen sich gerade
tendieren gerade hin zu blau das heißt
auch dort muss donald trump in den
verbleibenden stimmen deutlich mehr
stimmen holen als er bisher schon
ausgezählten stimmen für sich gewinnen
konnte und das ist ein szenario was
relativ unwahrscheinlich ist man kann
aber sagen wenn er nicht es schafft
arizona zurück zu erobern oder laut cnn
zu erobern dann fällt die tür für ihn
ins schloss mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren